how's it going bros and welcome to
[Music]
what
daisy today tuesday excellent how
disney releases posters in china uh-huh
okay no no
bruh i don't know if this is real it
wouldn't surprise me
i'm beginning to see a pattern here that
i'm not so sure i like hey there i
am i'm in the meme do you think uh
people that in china that watch black
panther
got rickroll they're like what what is
this
where's the logic i don't get it the
pewdiepie era it's 11 years oh [ __ ] we
hit 11 years did we really
oh hey yeah
screaming boy uh-huh angry teenager
uh-huh
family-friendly guy yeah that's right
loud viking
oh present very good
wait what the hell is this this better
not be a rick roll
i'm so sick of it it's copyrighted music
i'm just gonna
not use it
well i misjudged you severely and i
apologize
hell yeah hey oh yeah i can't show it
damn it i forgot
uh that is so dumb i can't
what is 20 21 help me that is so
dumb that is so dumb scythe how do we
get around this uh
it's a watermelon yeah watermelon yeah
it's a watermelon yeah well done youtube
mobile before you can pick any
quality youtube mobile now auto higher
picture quality
advanced ooh it's evolving just
backwards
well it looks like you can it's just a
simpler way come on
i doubt most people when i'm watching
this quality on their phone right
here's hitting 110 million subs on his
11th brave
110 million subs did i promise something
i feel like i i made a pro nah i can't
remember
i i no i never ah
[Music]
[Laughter]
all right guys i've always stayed true
to my promises so i guess i gotta do it
hey that's amazing holy [ __ ] an oil
painting
it took three thousand hours to complete
that's huge pp
huge pp right there and it's outdoors
cheese too you might very good
i like you girls doing puberty i hate
having uh-huh
boys doing parrot yeah get it they beat
their pee pee
[Music]
me to explain anything else about boys
i'm my boy i can explain
no i am men very strong
i know this isn't pea pie related but we
lost a legend goodbye spanish laughing
guy
no sorry for butchering your name
silent moment he had a great laugh but a
greater mustache
rest in peace oh no way dude
that is so awesome huge peepee
hell yeah my boys grew up
[Music]
that's so cool hell yeah uh you mixed
pewdiepie with pewdiepie and you got i
don't know what the [ __ ] that is looks
like an acid
lamb douchebag i don't like that get him
away from me skidaddle
shoosh douchey pie that's what we got
that's too much pewdiepie i don't like
it
whoa what what am i looking at
hell yeah i like it i love it now this
is fan art
holy [ __ ] what hi everyone i'm in
spanish
i hope his army like it well we do
mr pedro zorrella at some lengths
you finally capture them in its purest
essence
well done cheers to you mate a g fuel
sip in your honor
[Music]
that's sick i don't know what that uh
ken in pewte's videos casual dad ken in
his videos cool biker dad
wow yeah he's got that he went harder on
the american style on that video jesus
look at the cat looking good though
not gonna lie when you order your
invisibility cloak from china
it's transparent i feel like
invisibility cloak that someone's gotta
be able to invent that right
we looked into this me and dave because
we were curious they made like an
invisibility screen
which is pretty cool
that's sick right
what where'd it go where it go
i want it i want invisibility club i
want it i need it
i buy it ebay buy from wish you get this
[Music]
[Laughter]
all right petey died
classic classic
[Music]
that was beautiful cyber's gonna have to
murder it by adding another
background music but beautiful creation
of pewdiepie
humor okay i'll take it
why is it oh dark if you caught it
yeah that's like the only thing i got
going for me here
hell yeah i'm glad it's recognized
[Laughter]
felix nest oh [ __ ]
what cursed sauce is that
[Music]
[Applause]
i receive pewdiepie comment you receive
water bill reveal all right i got a
comment i gotta find this tick tock
this is so specific after all
why not why shouldn't i bark at it yeah
i mentioned that
edgar parks on bicycles that's like the
only thing he thinks is tough against
and someone made a meme out of it and
here we are
hell yeah yes
that's what i'm talking about [ __ ]
quality and you're all my brother's hate
quality
there we go glad we settled that kids i
challenged you to pokemon battle
whoa
[Music]
that is [ __ ] up pokemon is real
i knew it i knew it just first
invisibility cloak
we're living in the future
okay that's epic pewdiepie becomes first
youtuber to hit 110 million
subscribers hey dextero
base very nice thank you thank you
it's a lie but thank you bottom fruit
challenge
2021 we should do something else i feel
like it's such a dead meme but i will
challenge him
he just doesn't know it yet swedish kid
in school starts rambling in swedish all
the furniture around them
that's my pokemon right there i guess
i'm just a 3d printing guy now no way
that's so cool i love it you're gladly
that's an
honor how do you even 3d print thing i
don't know you can do different colors
austin bradley keep it up proud of you
i can't show um
it all gets copyrighted i don't know i
get the meme
i get it very good sometimes you just
got to commit to the rickroll
for people to stop it worked didn't it
have i gotten rickroll
no it's like fighting against bullies
you have to just
like yeah haha i am fat i guess and then
they stop
that's what you are you're a bunch of
bullies stop it
i hate the sod josh fight in nebraska
lars fight in sweden
glenn fight in gothenburg only swedish
people will get it
110 million subscribers 11 years of
youtube
perfectly balanced yes thank you so much
by the way that's [ __ ] awesome
okay so people want ken to get his own
border
color well i guess his should be a
cinnamon colored right
no one that you drunk friends
hell yeah i want to sing that song
karaoke it's [ __ ] slacks
i lied alright it's a good song but a
shitty meme come on
time for prince to see how big sven
would be in real life
holy sh such a weird photo
i love it that his nose is bigger than
edgar like come on
one in every six nine people
are subscribed to pewdiepie we did it
boys
we did it phase one is complete
phase two i don't know what the [ __ ] no
no what the hell did you do to it how is
that even possible
oh rip brother big f's in the chat oh
that
breaks my heart and he even had the
nicest color i don't even have
i don't know where i put it well i got
the glow in the dark one hey
guys check out do you feel like
description is always there
this shouldn't happen that's illegal you
should go to prison
i need a full story of what happened
where my bowels feeling where are they
where have you eaten them i'm sorry
edgar it had to be done
you were too strong you had to be nerfed
that game
[ __ ] sake this is never gonna stop now
jack realizing he's gonna host hawaii
there's only four jacksepticeye related
memes
you tried you tried it's okay we all
fail all the time
i don't know if i reacted to some of
these but according to a study
women are actually happier with less
attractive men
merch yeah yeah but mighty things bruce
willis
isn't handsome that's the thing so this
means nothing
nothing when you realize pewdiepie's put
yeah yeah yeah yeah
okay so i want to address this i don't
like pine
i don't i ordered a bunch of pie for a
video
to do it and i was like they smell bad i
don't want to eat them
sue me what are you gonna oh pie review
at 120 million subscribers can we get it
guys i promise i will deliver like all
my promises
10 year old me after giving dora the
explorer the wrong direction
go to hell dora people do that that's
cold
oh yeah that's such a good idea i
completely forgot about that
it's just uh can someone else do it so i
don't get in trouble
whoa hell yeah
i like it it looked like the statue of
liberty
[Laughter]
no okay so people were confused because
i said i never had a knock yet
what i meant was i never had the nokia
3310 or whatever the one everyone had
right the cool one
i had another schmick old ma nokia right
later on i'm glad i'm glad i was able to
address this because it's
it's uh it needed to be said i love this
meme that's great
uh thank you guys so much 410 million
subscribers
didn't think we were ever gonna hit that
it means a lot thank you
so smash that bro fish for friday
i'll see you guys tomorrow bye bye